i am now introducing the median string
problem
and to define this problem we need to
define the notion of distance
not only between k-mers of the same size
but also a distance between a k-mer and
a longer string
so what is this distance between two
strings of different lengths
we simply start from a smaller string
and
compare it to the first k-mer in the
text
distance in this case is 7 we move
further distance 6
continue continue continue continue
until the end of the string
and then return to the place where the
distance was minimal so in this way we
will find
a k-mer within a longer string that is
most
close to our camera of interest and this
is the distance between
pattern and string what is the distance
between a k-mer
and the set of strings in this case it's
simply
the sum of distances between a pattern
and
each string in the set and after so for
example for
pattern aaa and a set of strength shown
on this slide
we can compute distance with every
string
and then simply sum up all the distances
the result
is 5. a median string
for the set of string dna is a k-mer
pattern minimizing distance between
pattern
and dna over all possible k-mers
and our median string problem will be
based
on the problem we formulated before
which is yet another equivalent motif
finding problem
if you remember this problem then it
looks like even more complicated
than the original motif finding problem
because in this problem we need to find
a k-mer and a set of motifs
satisfying certain property but in fact
the only thing we need to find is a
k-mer pattern
as shown in this median string problem
in this case we search for a k-mer
pattern
minimizing distance between this pattern
and the set of strings dna
among all possible caves now
there is a very simple algorithm for
solving this problem we simply need to
try
all possible k-mers and see whether the
distance between
pattern a dna is minimal for each
camera monk all possible camera the
running time of this algorithm
is 4 to the power k and
t k where we deal with
t sequences of length n
so what we have just accomplished we
started from my tip finding problem
and the brute force algorithm for
solving this problem was
incredibly slow this turned it
into yet another equivalent motif
finding problem
and through this problem we were
able to switch to median string problem
with this
very different runtime in fact it's
still an exponential
algorithm but for practical applications
where k
is usually less than 15 we still can run
this algorithm
so dramatic improvement on the motif
finding problems that we started from
so sometimes change of perspective helps
and to move further we will
notice that also median string problem
is much faster than my keyfinding
problem this it's still slow
if we search for long motifs and a
little bit later
we will figure out how to deal with such
motifs
our last topic in this segment is
greedy motif search we'll now
talk about a grid algorithm for solving
motif finding problem
given a set of motifs we already learned
how to construct the consensus string
now let's construct the count matrix
where in every column we simply have
counts
of all nucleotides and also from this
count matrix can be transformed into
so-called profile matrix where we have
frequencies of nucleotides in every core
now these frequencies of nucleotides in
every column
can be viewed as a four-sided
bias dice representing probability
of ending cup of on a given phase
of a dice and we can can
view it as essentially as a probability
distribution
and if it is a die let's ask a question
what is the probability
that torsion such dye
based on the motifs will generate a
given
strength of dna for example what will be
the probability for generating a string
shown at this slide so
given the following profile we ask what
is the probability of generating the
consensus string
aaa cct
and this probability will be simply
computed by multiplication of
corresponding elements
in the profile matrix if we take another
string
we will get a different probability and
you have already noticed
that the closest string is to the
consensus strength of the profile
the higher is the probability of
generating
this strike and now we define the notion
of
profile most probable k-mer in a
sequence
this is a k-mer with the highest
probability
among all k-mers in the string
and here is an example of how i can
generate
profile most probable k-mer in a string
we start from first cameron strain
compute probability
and recorded in the last column of the
matrix we continue
until we fill all the matrix and finally
select the largest probability which in
this case
correspond to the red
entry in the matrix and with this at
hand
we are now ready for gradimative search
which works in a very simple way
we start from the set of i
minus one motifs selected
from the first i minus one sequences
and show how to extend this set of
motifs
by the motif in the eye sequence what we
do
we form profile of mighty from the first
i minus one sequences
and then select profile most probable
k-mer
in the sequence number i afterwards the
iterate
and that will result in the greedy
algorithm for solving the problem
and we will see later whether it works
or doesn't work
for our goals